if we take novel-writing so we're gonna
be spending a lot of detail on setting a
world but if we are doing a screenplay
are we really how much are we really
paying attention to like the where the
setting of the scenes is won't some of
that be fleshed out when the actual film
starts and the director storyboards or
whatever yeah um I mean I think that it
is important to pay attention to the
wear of your story right because every
choice that you make in your screenplay
should be a deliberate one so if you've
chosen a setting there should have been
some reasoning behind that you're not
gonna set your love story about you know
working with incarcerated writers you're
not gonna set that in a juvenile
detention center maybe you're you want
it to be in you know in a very specific
sort of like type of prison to inform
that world right so I think that you
should pay attention to the where if
we're talking about the the the process
of actually conveying that on the page I
think that you know the trick of
screenwriting right is to be as concise
as possible but as evocative as possible
as possible in those few words so so
that's the trick of conveying it on the
page is being deliberate about your
choice and then conveying it as
specifically as possible so that you can
get as much out of your choice as you
can does that make sense it does so fade
in if we're talking about let's say this
library this hypothetic
fade in that's what I'm having how much
do you tell me am i using up yeah well
so early in your screenplay you probably
because you're just introducing us to
the world of your story you'll probably
take a little bit more time to convey
where we are the the feel and the tone
of where we are and maybe the important
characteristics of that setting right
and then as your script progresses
you'll probably need to describe less
both because we're we've probably
already seen a lot of these locations
and then also because you want that you
want your story to move fast right so as
as you go further along in the
screenplay you'll probably spend less
time establishing locations than you did
at the very beginning when you were
trying to establish the world and create
that world in our minds so that we could
live in it for the duration of your
story now that said I think that there's
there's also value though in knowing
which moments in your screenplay should
breathe and when you have a moment that
you that you need to sort of give space
to that might be when you bring us into
the world for a little bit you no longer
of a moment with some extra detail or
telling us what's going on in that scene
or something like that
does that make sense it does yeah is
that the same for when we're doing a
character description in the beginning
like if we use this hypothetical
librarian she's 35 straight blonde hair
maybe a little bit dark under the eyes
from staying up all night reading yeah
so a lot of there's a lot of emphasis
put on those character introductions
right I think we I have two minds about
this I think that people get caught up
in writing like the perfect character
introduction I think that they are
important because the first time we meet
your character you want to give us a
sense of who they are sort of concisely
and evocatively right but you know I've
seen some character introductions that
that are that are a little too long that
maybe like stop the story in order to
give us a lot of information about the
character the moment we meet them which
can be you know if you're reading a
script it can it can really pull you out
if you if you are forced to stop the
scene and meet this person that feels
like it interrupts the flow of the story
right so I think the the trick of
writing character introductions again is
the same with with all screenwriting
which is be as concise as you can but as
evocative as you can and what you're
trying to convey when you introduce the
character is give us that sort of like
defining quality about them that
since of the character that's going to
be important to the story so physical
descriptions might not be as useful to
us right because we might I mean the
blond hair might never come into play in
the story right but it might be useful
to know that she's overworked or that
she's burning the midnight oil or you
know that might be important to the
story in the situation that she finds
herself in so stuff like that could be
useful and you just have to sort of
determine like what's the most sort of
defining quality about this character
that I need my reader to understand
right now as I introduce them
you